qu'est-ce que tu moi mon rêve c'est de
faire pékin express pékin express ça je
m'en occupe tout certain que j'aime avec
l'express en plus ils ont le souci de
vous
dis maman s'appelle louis et ses fans
rotenberg eux je dois signal taper tout
et cherchent des personnes lgbt et moi
j'en vois déjà pallem six
minutes à faire genre sable et j'appelle
qui misa d'art et maintenant le
producteur dan byrd s'est passé pas mal
de jeunes sinon
à part du japon n'était pas mort d'un
des leurs c'est fait
vous appelez-vous mac semble possible
si je crois pas je crois pas que ce soit
en passant par edipresse stéphane
c'est cyrille adoula c'est cyril hanouna
mon chéri ça va être mon chéri d'amour
chaud je suis à l'antenne show en direct
mon chéri de bouffer
est-ce que je décroche ou pas et la
toiture décrocher un stéphane déjà
stéphane
3-1 déjà je t'aime
c'est ce que je vais trop vite à des
jeunes et
je vais te dire quelque chose pourquoi
c'est moi qui paieraient
je vais te dire pourquoi j'aimerais
demander un petit service il ya tony qui
vaut à faire pékin express mais ce qui
s'est dit choqué et nous on aimerait
forcément s'en débarrasser
l'un dans l'autre on se rendrait
mutuellement service
[Rires]
par jour non mais ça demande partout
alors
j'appelle beaucoup de monde pour envoyer
des chroniqueurs de l'émission
là quelqu'un pour envoyer dans une
émission c'était daniel moreau c'était
sur france 3 c'était pour une émission
sur la mort
à tous et à 2804
non je tiens les gens dans la rue me
demande quelque chose
vous faites
c'est pas mal mais si te connais
ni donc au final ils voient que
c'est qu'ils produisent
c'est qui qui produit pékin express déjà
ému
thierry guillaume chocolat amer
maintenant c'est chez moi cette photo
nous y voilà j'adore qui relie aussi qui
est super je rappelle très bien c'est un
très bon animateur mais là pas l'air
chaud stéphane s'il a l'air chaud
stéphane kochoyan stéphanois qui n'est
pas chaud il s'épanouit à stéphane joly
stéphane quand il dit quelque chose il
le fait voilà
c'est maintenant juste à pas nicolas
terrano parce que budgétairement j'ai
peur que ça
[Rires]
non mais je vais devoir manquer la
mission
être avec toi avec grand plaisir tu sais
que je t'aime
tu réfléchis et si tu veux tu sais ce
qu'on va faire on va sarah desjeunes et
là dans les quinze jours c'est pour moi
et je vais te remettre au tennis en
commençant inquiète pas t je vais te
dire on démarre par une bulle et après
on s'envole c'est ce que disait toujours
bien federer ce qui m'a tant donné et un
très bon potentiel est une merveille
t'embrasser panon thème qu'est-ce qui
les font que là
c'était parce que stéphane c'est pas le
genre à dire oui dans les règles dans
les cabinets j'adore ce mec ouais mais
c'est pas mal on avance